the charges today relate in no way to
Russian collusion WikiLeaks
collaboration or any other illegal act
in connection with a 67 count indictment
I think it's a very serious one but it
shows that the special counsels office
is uncovering the evidence it needs this
has nothing to do with the president has
nothing to do with the White House and
this connection to the battle was their
illegal collusion illegal conspiracy
with Russia we don't find it well seven
count indictment for Roger stone and in
that indictment a number of different
parts of it but this says after the July
22nd 2016 release of stolen DNC emails
by organization one that's WikiLeaks a
senior Trump campaign official was
directed to contact stone about any
additional releases and whether other
damaging information organization one
had regarding the Clinton campaign stone
therefore thereafter told the Trump
campaign about potential future releases
of damaging material by organization one
again WikiLeaks the counts that stone
now faces one count of obstruction of an
official proceeding up to five years
their five counts of false statements
five years per count potentially one
count of witness tampering and there's
up to twenty years in prison for that
meaning he's facing a maximum of fifty
years in prison Rudy Giuliani the
president's attorney putting in a
statement saying the indictment today is
yet again nothing more than another
false statement charge it doesn't allege
collusion indeed the charges no
underlying wrongdoing by mr. stone or
anyone else seems like we are coming to
an end what about all this let's digest
it with our panel bring them back byron
york chief political correspondent of
washington examiner josh crash our the
political editor for the national
journal and matthew cottan a tea editor
in chief of the washington free beacon
okay Matthew what do you make of the
Roger stone indictment well what
happened to Richard Nixon and Watergate
is a tragedy Brett but Roger stone seems
to have read it as an instruction manual
the indictment is correct and
nonetheless the crime for which he was
indicted are processed crimes they're
not the crimes that Muller was appointed
to investigate and so I think the
administration is able to create some
space between what happened Roger stone
and the President himself Josh you know
it does feel like the walls are closing
in when it comes to the Trump White
House and impossible connections with
Russia and WikiLeaks stone is merely one
of one of the many campaign officials on
that Trump campaign to now be indicted
and and it feels like the heat is on in
the White House on the other hand from
the political point of view if you
remember back in the summer of 2016
Trump was calling publicly on Russia to
release the the emails and and stone was
tweeting about this it's for everyone
who follows him on Twitter to see so
this was sort of baked in politically to
the 2016 election and I don't think the
public and it certainly the politics of
this changes until Muller releases his
report and actually there is some
evidence of collateral collusion which
there has not been proven to be so far
so the politics I don't think we really
change a whole lot even though this is
yet another damning connection from that
Trump campaign to Russia well what we
don't know Byron is the senior Trump
campaign official who is ordered to talk
to stone and you know the White House
and everyone and Rudy Giuliani is saying
it doesn't touch the president obviously
he was intimately involved in the
campaign so we don't know a lot from
this indictment even though it's seven
counts and laid out well that passage
that you read and that you just referred
to about July 22nd 2016 is very
important one of the most important
things being it's after the WikiLeaks
WikiLeaks is published we find out that
WikiLeaks has or the Russians have
hacked the DNC WikiLeaks discloses its
stuff and after it happens someone in
the Trump campaign says to stone what's
going on so that suggests that there was
no knowledge beforehand and also I think
that does not really support any idea
that there was some sort of collusion
scheme or
conspiracy going on between the Trump
campaign and Russia but the the main
thing to remember reading this
indictment is Roger stone has always
been kind of a BS artist he brags about
all sorts of dirty deeds some of which
he hasn't even done and he was doing
that in connection to this case in
public and then the house had him come
for an interview and asked him about
those statements under oath and he
allegedly lied about it all and it is
all kind of caught up with him but as
far as is revealing some sort of scheme
or conspiracy just doesn't do it take a
listen very quickly to the question of
whether Roger stone would flip for the
special counsel and sometime somehow
testify against the president there is
no circumstance president when you're
facing long prison term the most loyal
of people turn to themselves and say I
have to look out for myself first you
get ten years in jail but if you say bad
things about somebody in other words
make up stories it's called flipping and
it almost ought to be illegal so Matthew
it doesn't sound like he's going to do
that but will here on Tucker show at 8
p.m. tonight no it doesn't sound it all
but I would say the way in which the FBI
apprehended stone in that 6 a.m. raid
involving so many agents with weapons
for what are as you know basically
perjury or witness tampering in terms of
a congressional investigation in a
Special Counsel investigation I think
shows the Special Counsel trying to
ratchet up the pressure which will
continue as this legal process moves on
Brett and as you mentioned before these
charges can amount to some significant
prison time and I think that's something
that Moeller is going to emphasize in
his dealings with stone